I think it's a great that it another way
of telling stories the idea that they
put it all up in one day as opposed to
doing the episodic thing now the master
ball just did an article about how that
affected social media because people
with you know with walking dead and Sons
of Anarchy it was a lot of upset as a
heart so people tweet about it when
they're watching it live because house
of cards is a really long movie that
netflix put up at once it had a higher
spike at the beginning and then really
love all I think that it's Netflix isn't
going to say with the numbers they're
never going to say what the ratings is
great but I don't know my only I like
the idea of been viewing and I like the
idea of them not putting ratings out but
what I'm concerned about is how much
that does affect the social
that would they would they have them
better to put it out every week and I
think that's really going to be a time
will tell and I think that's another
thing with kind of seeing the matrix
does netflix sees binge viewing I see
how that works no one else has their
point of view no one else can see what
people are watching the way they
so I they have an advantage it's like
Nielsen ratings plus the matrix I mean
they can really know what every
subscriber is doing in a way that no
network and ever even HBO can't get that
kind of specific numbers because it's
all online it's all IP addresses but i
think it's it's it's great that there is
now another way to tell gigantic stories
with big names in a way that HBO did in
a way that no one's never been done
before this is it's it's it's
history-making at someone and it'll be
interesting to see what happens with the
rest of development I think that's the
one because that has a pre-existing
audience house of cards was a remake of
a British miniseries so I think when
when arrested development goes that's
going to be the one to watch to see how
that because it's short episodes people
watch the whole thing weekend if
and I think that's what that'll be the
one to watch to see how Netflix handles
binge viewing putting stuff out quickly
and how the social media stuff
i well I think it's gonna I think it's
going to have a much bigger spike than
house of cards I think it's going to
have
a longer tail than house of cards and
because they will have a house of cards
is another season I'm told where the
movie for rest development which will
have nothing to do with Netflix is story
is what's out there so I think that
pre-existing audience that built over
this time then gets 13 episodes were
ever to putting out that will spike
that'll bring in two more people and
then that they can go from the movie so
I think that because there's
anticipation of more story I think that
the buzz go billiards I think it will
build a little bit faster and I think
more people will watch arrested
development then launched house of
course just because of the content
content I I had thought about when we
were working on when season three was
when I thought to be shooting season 3
right now I thought about just putting
the whole thing out yeah once
with play shorts the new project I
always planned on weekly because it's a
different story every week and I need
that bugs I need that conversation and
it's going to be a different story a
different conversation different
questions and at different audience
members a completely and of the audience
already have some will be responding to
those stories differently because you
know vampire mob is a story about a hit
man who's the mob use a vampire a lot of
people look at a gun bleh sure it will
be different every time I think it
appeals to a completely different people
and some of the same so I think that's I
don't over the question was I think if
they
I know some people have done a thing
where though they're showing at a
festival and then they do a very limited
online window where it's up I think
that's that's a good idea I think it
really
depends on how big your network is you
can definitely have more conversation a
foul if you're putting out something
slowly week after week after week I
suppose just putting out here's here's
hour and a half here's the whole thing
going 10 minutes 10 minutes if the story
form fits that on the flip side in terms
of the long tail I'm finding way more
people watch vampire mob has six
episodes in the first season eight and
second I have them both office two
videos most people are watching the tube
videos and watching it at once they're
not watching the individual episodes
anymore at all it's really more of a
single video so I think the long tail
people would rather sit back and just
watch the whole thing my advice if you
are if you do put on a web series or
anything individual put out the
individual episodes and then after it
has sort of run its little heart bring
it back out is 11 video is now I have a
forty nine minute video up on YouTube in
a 30 minute 27 minute video
or the two videos on YouTube and I think
people are sitting back and watching
them just like they watching the lure
netflix or anything else I think that
it's it's about behavior it's not about
emulations it's about what the future
behavior is going to be and I think a
netflix join with that YouTube has been
time without for years and continues to
alert hits audience's attention fragment
over and over and over continuously and
I think that if you're an independent
storyteller and it fits to put out
individual episodes if you have a short
amount of storing and it works you're
not just telling all starring
cutting it up vampire mom was written
individually I think it's a way to keep
the conversation going longer I think if
you you know if you were going to take a
feature in and just chop it up I would
put it out there longer pieces I think
the three the five-minute thing is over
I don't I think you're at least at ten
minutes unless it really fits what
you're doing a 10 minute cat video is
too long
but three to five minute cat video might
be perfect depending on the cash and the
video and if someone gets hit in the
ball yeah Dennis guaranteed others